Welcome to "Learning the YouTube
APIs in 10 Minutes."
I'm your host, Jeremy Walker.
I'm a YouTube developer
advocate.
So let's get started.
I'm first going to talk to you
about the Analytics API
itself, and then I'm going to
talk to you about defining a
report and taking that
information and testing your
report so you can basically
get an idea of if
it's working or not.
And then from there, we'll
take that information and
quickly move it into
some code.
Now, the first three sections,
doesn't matter what language
you're using.
The last section, I will use
Java, but you can see from the
end of it when you actually go
through it that you can apply
this to any language you
want to go with.
So, the YouTube Analytics
API--
if you're used to YouTube, you
know that there's a bunch of
data, and we provide an
Analytics window where you can
get a lot of that
in a dashboard.
But you may want to mash up
those reports in different
ways, or combine it with other
data, or even automate
processes to handle that data.
And we let you do that
through our API.
It's a HTTP RESTful API.
So you can write the URIs
yourself, or we provide nine
libraries, so you can
pick the library
that fits your language.
We also have a lot of examples
so you don't have to write
code from scratch.
You can just grab ours and
tinker with it a little bit to
fit your needs.
So let's get started and
define your report.
So there's two types of
reports you can get.
You have a channel and a
content owner report.
Today we're going to cover
channel report, which is
basically just getting
information just for a
specific channel.
For partners who have multiple
channels, they can do a
content owner report, where they
can get information on
one of their channels or all of
their channels and kind of
bundle it together.
I will be giving a talk on
that at I/O that will be
recorded, so you'll be able to
watch that as well if you're
interested.
But again, this presentation
here actually applies to both,
so I would definitely recommend
going through this
and then jumping to that.
So when you start with a report,
after you've decided
on whether it's going to be a
channel report or a content
owner report, now you have
to decide OK, what
information do I need?
And that's where the big
three come into play.
So there's metrics, which are
the most important one.
Those are going to be any sort
of activity or user activity
that we record--
so views, likes, uniques,
subscribers added, loss, all
that great stuff.
So that's kind of the metric
you're looking for-- well,
metric, of course.
And then we kind of bundle those
together in what are
called dimensions.
So when you get views, you have
to get a dimension on it
so you can decide on, you want
it by days, or you want it by
week or month, or maybe you
want it by country.
So we give you a bunch of those
options because you can
kind of bundle it
how you want.
Now if you don't want all that
information and you want to
filter it a little bit, we have
filters, so you can--
for instance, if you want views
and you take them by
country, but maybe you're only
interested in Japan, then you
can set a filter to
only get Japan.
And after you come up with the
metrics and dimensions and
possible filter you want, then
you're going to want to look
at our page that's labeled
Available Reports.
And I can show that
to you right here.
So if you just search for the
YouTube Analytics API, this
will be what comes up.
And under reports, because you
have to choose one, you can
choose Channel Reports which
is what I'm doing here.
And you can see available
reports.
So what this is is it's a bunch
of information about
what metrics and dimensions work
with each other because
you can't just throw them
all together and
hope it will work.
There's only certain
reports that will
work with each other.
So you have to kind of go
through this and make sure
it's working.
So in this case, I'm actually
going to look at
just getting the views.
Now, you can see here,
for metrics, I
combined a bunch of these.
I could combine views, comments,
favorites added, a
bunch of stuff.
And then I can do it on a
dimension by day, seven-day
totals, or a month.
I'm actually going to show
you an example--
a month--
but you can combine those two,
and on the right, you can
filter, either by country or by
video, which is a video ID,
and then from there by country
if you choose to do so.
So again, you kind of put your
report together, get a rough
idea with the big three, and
then you look at the available
reports for either the content
owner or channel-- in our
case, channel--
and you decide what you
want to do from there.
So now that you've kind of got
the report you want, or
possibly reports you want,
the next step is to
go to the API Explorer.
Now this is a really, really
powerful tool that's available
on our website that basically
lets you run reports without
writing any code, including
authorization.
Because with the Analytics
API, you do have to
authorize--
this is really important.
Because then you get the report
working and in great
shape before you
go to the code.
I see a lot of people who start
writing code and then
they say they're having
problems, when it's just that
they never had a proper
report to begin with.
So always start with this.
That's a best practice.
And how this works is, again,
you just search YouTube
Analytics API, and this
will come up.
And if you go the Reference
link, you'll see we have some
great information.
Again, there's a RESTful API,
so if you want don't want to
use our libraries and you want
to just construct the URLs
yourself, you can do that.
We list all the parameters.
And then we even provide some
examples in Python,
JavaScript, in Java and Ruby,
and then we have some more
libraries beyond that.
But at the bottom of the page is
this API Explorer, is what
we call it.
And so this is where you can
try out your reports before
you dive into code.
So you can see in the
right here, there's
this Authorize Request.
I just hit that I want
to authorize that.
And then now it's authorized,
so now I can run requests as
if I've gone through the whole
OAuth 2 process, which
actually is done on
the background.
So let's get started.
So you can see at the bottom
here, we have Metrics,
Dimensions, Filters,
which were the big
three I'm talking about.
You can see above that Start
Date and End Date.
It's pretty self-explanatory.
But at the top, you
can see IDs.
And this is what you actually
use to specify which channel
report you want.
So do you want a channel
report, or a
content owner report?
If you're doing a content owner,
you'd just type in
contentowner== and then
your content owner ID.
But in this case, we're doing
a channel report, so you'd
just do channel== and then
you'll do your channel ID.
Now, you're probably not going
to know your channel ID.
Most people don't.
It's this long string with a
bunch of numbers and letters.
So that, actually, you have
to get from the Data API.
So we have another API that's
part of the YouTube API family
which is called the Data API.
And this lets you do
most everything
you can do on YouTube.
And one of those things
is to get
information on your own channel.
So we're going to actually
do that.
And if you just search for the
YouTube Data API, it'll be the
first thing that comes up.
It's also in the same area
as the Analytics API.
But here you see V3 comes up.
And if you expand the
reference, you'll
see there's a channel.
And I will actually want
the list function.
Again, this lists out.
This looks pretty probably
almost just like what you just
saw in the Analytics API page.
But you can see we list all the
parameters so you can make
the URL yourself.
And then at the bottom, we have
the API Explorer again,
so this is great.
This will actually give me my
channel ID, so I'm just going
to authorize this
really quickly.
And then I'm just going
to put the ID--
I could put "snippet" in if
I want more information.
And what's nice is you can just
set mine equal to "true."
So this will get the channel
associated with my account,
which is right here, which
is the perfect one.
And here is the ID.
So I'm just going to grab
this and drop it here.
Now I'm pretty much set to go,
so I can start setting dates.
I'm actually going to run a
monthly report, so I'm going
to run it for October
and November.
So I just set my times here.
My metric, I just want "views."
Dimensions, I'm going
to do "month." And then I'm not
going to do any filter at
this point.
But I hit execute, and then you
can see it constructs the
actual URL that goes out, and a
little bit more information,
and then actually shows
you the response.
You can see I got 1,100
views in November and
about 2,000 in October.
So this is kind of
a great tool.
You can kind of mess around a
lot with it until you get your
report just right.
And if you wanted to see filter,
let's say I wanted to
see country.
We'll go with Brazil, see
what that pulls up.
And OK, I have one in three
views in Brazil.
So that's just an example
of what you can do.
If I wanted to, I could also
drop a video in here and grab
the video ID and put that in
there, or whatever it may be.
So anyway, I have my report.
I'm all set.
Everything's looking good.
The nice thing now is when I
jump into coding, a lot of
these parameters here map
directly to the client
library, so you pretty much know
where to plug and play.
So let's jump into that.
So I've told you a little
bit about the API.
We've defined a report.
We've actually run it.
Everything looks good.
Now we just add it
to our code.
So in this case, I'm
going to use Java.
If you look here, I'm actually
constructing a HTTP transport
object in a JSON factory.
These are just to handle the
requests and responses.
And you'll see here
is a credential.
I don't have all the
coding here.
Again, this is an example
that's online, so
you can go grab it.
There's a larger function
that takes care of the
credentials for you.
I'm not going to go over that,
but it takes care of the whole
OAuth 2 process, so you can
have a look at that.
But the gist of this page is
that, hey, I'm setting up a
YouTube object and a YouTube
Analytics object.
And the YouTube object maps to
the Data API because I need to
get my channel ID, right?
The other one is YouTube
Analytics, which is where I'm
going to run my report.
So next thing I need to do is
first get the channel ID.
And you can see I just call in
the YouTube object Channels
List, and then I set mine, which
if you look at the API
Explorer, it's pretty much
exactly what I set.
So again, you don't actually
need snippet.
I was just showing that so you
could see it was my channel.
So I just set ID there,
because I just
really need the ID.
I execute it, and then I would
get a list back of channels.
And the first one would
be my default one.
So now that I have that,
I just run a report--
analytics.reports.query--
and then I just drop in
the same information--
channel== and then that channel
ID, and then I do the
dates, and then set
the dimensions.
And then if I had any
filters, I could set
them there as well.
And then I execute that.
That'll give me a result table
object that will have all the
information that I can run
through with, my own function.
So let's see what
that looks like.
So this is all that stuff
you just saw.
And I'll actually clear this
out, and I'll rerun it.
So this is actually going
out, and I've
already set up the OAuth.
So you can see it pulled from
my default channel, and you
can see the numbers
are the same.
So that gives you an idea how
to get started really quick.
I've gone over the Analytics
API, kind of what it's used
for, to match up reports,
automated things, and combine
maybe external data
with your data.
I've gone over defining a
report, testing it out with
the API Explorer-- which is
very, very important.
Make sure you do that.
That's a big, big
best practice.
And then you port that
over to your code.
I happened to show Java, but
again, you could have done
this in Ruby, Objective
C, whatever you want.
So now you should be set to go
and have some fun with the
Analytics API.
So if you want to learn more,
search YouTube Analytics API.
You can follow my team on
google.com/+YouTubeDev.
And then you can follow
me as well--
google.com/+JeremyJWalker.
Thank you for your time.